- [Voiceover] This is me suffering
from another anxiety attack in Dallas,
24 hours after bullet casings
were picked up from the streets,
I went to Dallas.
24 hours before that,
I was at a black lives matter protest.
If you were to ask me how Dallas was,
I could not deliver a quick summary,
but I can tell you all the things
that ran through my mind,
because they haven't left me.
Instead of visiting
Dallas to go see museums
and eat barbecue,
my hotel sat right across the street
from where the shooting took place.
I couldn't eat,
and I couldn't sleep,
so I just did what I do best,
and that's film.
Children, some who didn't understand,
and unfortunately some who did,
and it was not about a city divided,
but a city that came together in mourning,
and now their lives
are stricken with fear.
I thought about how many
anxiety attacks I had
in one week.
It was six.
I couldn't breathe,
and all I wanted to do was breathe.
- I thank you for the love.
You know, love travels a long ways.
- [Voiceover] And, I met a homeless woman,
and I thought about the
last time I had cried,
so I cried with her.
- Thank you.
- Just coming together as a community,
that's what we really need to do.
- [Voiceover] My Uber drivers
became taxi cab confessionals.
Some revealing how they were
in the midst of the tragedy.
I didn't want to remember
Dallas for its tragedy,
but even as I tried to leave Dallas,
the security level was so high
that it was hard to leave,
and even as I did,
all I could think about were the people
that were left behind with pain.
When I got to the airport
I looked up to the news
and saw that there was
shooting in Michigan
not too far from my grandfather,
and it made me think,
in the midst of tragedies like Orlando,
Baton Rouge, Minnesota, and now Dallas,
where was I going to travel to next?
(upbeat music)